porter moser head coach of chicago hey
coach how you doing
i'm great guys how are you we are doing
so well so glad to uh actually have an
ncaa tournament to be talking about i
know uh
the only people happier than us are the
guys that are that are playing in it and
coaching in it like you are
um congratulations by the way you guys
are just the third team to beat a number
one seed in the second round by
double digits led wire to wire over
number one seed uh illinois
um what has this ride been like for you
i know you made the final four a couple
of years ago so i don't want to say
you're used to it but this is not new at
least for a couple of the uh
the older guys in your team you know we
got we got two guys that were on that
team uh lucas williamson and cameron
crowe but everybody else is new
so what's what's really great about this
is just being able to sustain it
the program and just uh it's a big
reason why i stayed is just what you
know feeling like you can just keep
building
something special and uh all the things
we had to go through this year the
twists and turns the pivots
to get to this point and you know to get
in here and then
you know in our state of illinois two
ranked teams going at each other
to go to the sweet 16. the storyline
couldn't have been better
for the loyal ramblers going into this
thing oh it was an unbelievable
storyline and oh by the way
you guys get a play with a big old chip
on your shoulder because the committee
i think screwed the pooch giving you
guys an eight seed when you've been
ranked in the top 25 for
over a month and you're top 10 in the
net and ken palm and
all these other metrics what did you say
to your guys when when you got that
eight seat
you know what i'm always uh talking to
him about control you can control
so he you know i part of that we all
kind of knew we were like you know what
all right let's roll with it let's just
go
and because you know the crazy thing
about it is they came up with the net
and what does the net stand for it's the
ncaa evaluation
tool that's what they said they were
going to use and we were nine
so the one through four got all the one
seeds
five through eight got all the two seeds
and the ninth
got the ac so it just is what it is i
know it's a hard job i know they got
things so
we really didn't make that big of a a
chip on our shoulder kind of thing we
just
said all right let's go let's all about
pouring into georgia tech
and we beat them and then it was all
about illinois and that's kind of what
we did last time
we didn't worry about a lot of the
outside stuff it was just what was in
front of us and
our guys our guys just are really close
really together and just have this
confidence
that they believe they can win the
national championship and last time we
were seven minutes away and
we know we got some obstacles in front
of us but our guys believe
dan helly filling on the rich eisen show
with porter moser the
head coach coach at loyola chicago i
coach i have to ask you because i was
doing a little deep dive and watching
some youtube videos with some interviews
and podcasts that you've done and
there was i can't remember who it was
but he talked about what great friends
you guys were at the top of the podcast
and then mispronounced your last name
and you called him right from the jump
and i love that is somebody who gets my
name mispronounced all the time
i i really appreciated that i think it
was tim miles
it was yeah yeah and he was a great
friend of mine
and uh i was just joking with him when
he said that he just he said mosher
on that
is it 50 50 the amount of people that
say moser as opposed to moser
you know what exactly it is it's
actually more say moser like it's
sh and i really could care less i'm not
one of those guys i really don't care um
but i just had to bust tim's chops on it
i love it i love it why
i thought that was pretty funny as i
said you know my last name's helly and i
can't tell you how often people just
don't want to say hell
so they'll say healy or halle i'm like
it's heli
it's just a norwegian name coach nothing
i can do about it
um hey so i love the emphasis on defense
you guys are the best defensive team in
the country
and i'm wondering it's so hard so many
coaches
preach defense but but you manifest it
you make it happen your players make it
happen but
you you you guide them along in that
process does this go
all the way back to when you attended a
bobby knight camp when you were a kid
this love of defense no i wish i could
say that but no
i don't even have my memory that long um
the uh i tell you what you know i worked
for rick majers and um
you know he was so good defensively but
i think that's how we frame it you know
with our guys in the recruiting process
you know sometimes you say oh we're
gonna play defense they think oh we're
gonna slow it down we gotta play
but we kind of frame it like our defense
creates offense
you know we we get stops we can run we
we get steals we can run
and we talk about it we frame it with
how like
in the pros everyone's talking about
two-way players you know kobe
michael kwai klay thompson you know
two-way players
and we frame it that way hey you're
going to learn we're going to play great
defense we're going to create offense we
are going to run because we've been up
in the top
you know 40 and offensive efficiency as
well
and uh so i think it's how you frame it
the guys believe in it they don't think
we're just going to walk it up they
think we're going to guard our tails off
get stops and run so they they really
believe it's a it's a way we can win
having crotwig and williamson there is
your as your senior leaders who have
been there before how much do you lean
on these two guys
you know what it's huge because you know
so we won the missouri valley tournament
two weeks ago
and we cut down the nets we're
celebrating you can see all the guys
because
we're we got a lot of new guys and they
were just so excited and we had a
celebration cut up we were in the locker
room
and those two were like you guys this is
awesome but it gets a lot better
and when you gotta when you guys got
voices that come from your peers your
your friends it just carries more weight
because the coach can always say that
hey i've been there before you know we
got to do this
but when those guys said it hey it gets
a lot better from here we got to lock in
you know we can advance and believe you
can advance in this thing
and uh just huge just having those two
guys been on that stage at the final
four
uh a couple years ago oh it's also huge
to have
101 year old sister jean she became a a
phenomenon
nationally uh just beloved by everybody
when you guys made the uh final four run
a couple of years ago the pre-game
speech before the illinois game
do you give her a a scouting report or
is she doing this on her own
i mean she just looks at the stats and
she you know she's she said you know she
is
it's funny sometimes she'll say oh watch
out for number 35. you know she's
she's unbelievably sharp now um but it's
funny how
it's kind of morphed into a scouting
report
it's amazing but she's so much a part of
who we are fabric she does give
the guys a blessing before they go and
you know this this time through the
phone
but um you know for 101 years old she
still emails us
each one of us after the game every game
and she's just really sharp and
you know she's um she's woven in the
fabric of who we are
hold on a second she when you say each
one of us
as in just the coaching staff the
players everybody
no i get a personal email then she sends
each player a personal email after every
game
that's incredible yeah every game
my in-laws who are far from 101 do not
send emails that's that's impressive
well my i want to correct myself my
father-in-law does my mother-in-law
doesn't so they could be watching right
now
i don't want to get injured that's how
you get yourself in trouble with the
in-laws
see you you know about that what is uh
was it
was there a question mark about her
coming i would imagine being a
101 and she insisted right she
arch madness which is the missouri
valley tournament in st
louis they didn't let her go and then i
talked to her after we got back
and she was pissed and she was like
um right
i looked them all in the eye and said
i'm healthier than all you i've been
vaccinated i got 30
straight tests i'm going and right then
i knew that like she's she's getting her
way
and uh sure enough she's here and
everybody's fired up that she's up in
the
in the balcony sister jean is a beast i
love it
oh gosh
team to watch it's fun to watch you guys
play she's a great story i
i love your ties to rick majerus he was
one of my favorite coaches
just from afar um you know when he was
at
uh utah way back in the day i loved the
way that his
his team played and um i saw that you
started journaling
which is something that i've been
telling myself for the last decade that
i'm going to do and i have yet to do it
but you started doing that because of
majerus is that right
yeah that's right it's just you know one
it was just every day i was just
learning stuff so i had like a
basketball journal going
and then i had another side one of just
crazy hilarious stories
and i'm like i gotta start writing this
down i mean there's just so much that
was
you know and then we get together of
guys that were that played for him and
then coached with them
we'll see each other and we'll just
start telling stories and just laugh
and so i started writing them down i got
about 100 pages just hilarious stories
i'll sit up on my fire pit sometime and
just start laughing
rehashing some of the story he meant so
much to me but he was also a great
friend
hilarious guy so much fun but he was a
genius just sitting there in the my four
years i spent as associate head coach
at st louis we just sitting in a board
room and like
watching his mind twist and turn and
game playing and it was it was like i
was getting a phd from the guy he
just meant a lot to me he's gone way too
early
did you you you've written a book using
some of those stories is that right or
no
no no that was a different like i always
thought if i was
going to write a book it was going to be
you know remember how steve alford had a
book and he put it out
it was called playing for night right
and i remember reading a cover to cover
like and i just thought it was riveting
just what was it like to play for night
and i got i get asked the question all
the time especially my first
you know why i was working for him it'd
be like hey what's it like working for
magears
everyone always asks me that question so
i was gonna write i was my mind was
always going to write a book called
working for majerus and then i got
after the final four i got approached by
the loyal of jesus press i'm like
i think they want a different path for
this book it was
it was more of my path my journey of
faith and uh
my journey of how i got to loyola and
got to the final four and um so i ended
up doing that but someday i might do it
someday i might do with something and
and it will be won't be disparaging at
all it'll be more honoring him but
telling funny stories of how
you know because there was no one like
him there was no one like him in our
profession
yeah he was one of the all-time greats
and uh and definitely uh
missed by all college basketball fans
around the country um
i i do need to ask you about what you
have coming up uh the midwest region
is just completely turned upside down
you guys
are despite being the the eight seed uh
coming in you're the second highest seed
remaining
and and now you have oregon state coming
up what's the what's the scouting report
do you have one yet on the beavers
yeah i mean they're they're very good
they're very hot i mean think about this
we drew the acc tournament champs
they were hot coming in then we drew the
big ten champs they were hot coming in
now we're drawing the pac-12 tournament
champs
three straight tournament champs of
power five
conferences so you know they they're
very well coached coach kenko does an
awesome job
they're they're hot they're shooting it
they got a big man they got a great
point guard
um you know they're gonna be hard to
guard and i think that's a big part of
it and
then you look at the defense on the
other two games with syracuse and
houston
you've got two contrasting styles you've
got houston who probably played some of
the best man-to-man physical defects in
the country
and then you got syracuse who just has
that long long zone
that you just got to figure out and
they're shooting it well so
some very hot teams um coming in here in
these last four teams
finally before we let you go dan helly
filling in for rich eisen with uh porter
moser
loyal chicago head coach uh coach what
are you
what are you doing to keep busy when you
guys aren't practicing and playing
are you guys do you have everything
scheduled out every hour we're doing
this we're watching games together as a
team or do guys get
free time i know there's really nowhere
to go to kind of do their own thing
so that's a great question uh dan helly
there we go i love the enunciation
i listen um no but i tell you that's a
when we got here we had to go to
quarantine so we got here sunday night
we actually watched selection show
in the indy 500 speedway which is really
cool they let us take our buses around
because once you check in the hotel you
had to test and get put in quarantine
and i'm like i'm watching the selection
show with my guys right i'm not doing it
separate our rooms
so we checked in sunday night tested had
the quarantine woke up
had to test again quarantine again so
then once it was almost monday night
when you got out so really tuesday
wednesday thursday you're
you're practicing preparing and you
don't get to go out outside much
but this is the week that we got to be
really uh
aware because another week here you we
haven't had much time to go outside they
really got you in a bubble
um the has been really well organized
with the testing and all that
it's just there's some downtime and this
it's going to be this week so we've been
coming up with some things to get these
guys mentally
uh loose and free and and just so much
where they get out and do some things so
this week is the big week for for this
yeah that's gonna be uh that's gonna be
maybe your most challenging job is to
find stuff for uh
for the kids to do we talked to paul
mills oral roberts head coach they're
playing it they're playing a kickball
game staff versus team
so maybe that gives you an idea of you
know something no are they going outside
are they able to go out they're probably
going to go during you get like a half
hour outside
so we were throwing around a football a
couple days ago that was
one thing we had a football in the
baseball field the guys were throwing it
they had a soccer ball
but uh i like the kickball idea yeah i'm
great at wiffle ball too i am i'm like
i'm a phenomenal with football players
so you can hit that
oh yeah i grew up in chicago you play
16-inch softball in chicago and whiffle
ball
two great ones ah chicago guy porter
moser
hey coach good luck man we're all
rooting for you uh it's been a pleasure
talking to you i really appreciate the
time
and um enjoy every minute of it i know
you are
thanks guys we'll see you hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here